president chomp is back in the u.s.
following his historic summit in
Singapore with kim janghoon
the president is now saying there's no
need to worry about a nuclear threat
from North Korea the commander in chief
is also sitting down with Brett Baier
telling him US combat troops will remain
on the Korean Peninsula is the military
drawing down in South Korea you kind of
hinted at that and is there going to be
this kind of tit-for-tat
no it's not drawing down at all in fact
honestly was never discussed I'm sure
he'd like that it was never on the table
we sort of understood that was never on
the table with that being understood and
and you know you asked me a question
like that I would love to get the
military out as soon as we can because
it costs a lot of money a lot of money
for us we don't get paid fully for that
military which you know I'll be talking
to South Korea about but we have 32,000
soldiers in South Korea I'd like to get
him home I would like to but it is not
on the table right now at the
appropriate time it will be the full
interview airs on special report tonight
at 6:00 p.m. Eastern over in South Korea
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo says the
u.s. wants to see Kim jong-un making
progress towards a denuclearization
before the end of trumps first term this
while the president is taking aim at the
mainstream media for negative coverage
of his landmark sit-down tweeting so
funny to watch the fake news especially
NBC and CNN they are fighting hard to
downplay the deal with North Korea 500
days ago they would have begged for this
deal look like war would break out our
country's biggest enemy is the fake news
so easily promulgated by fools you're an
expert in promulgated by fools yeah I am
you know we're all here everybody here
by nature is skeptical
we're skeptical about everything and I
find it I guess funny that the least
skeptical people on earth are demanding
that we be skeptical so these are the
people that smear you if you are
skeptical about Cuba or climate change
models or stats on mass shootings or gun
control talking points if you're
skeptical about the Paris Accords if
you're skeptical about Iran if you're
skeptical about communism social
in venezuela if you're skeptical about
that you're heartless but you must be
skeptical about this well we're already
there we've always been skeptical if you
were to if you were a conservative or a
libertarian
you're born skeptical right I'm gonna
pull Dana Perino I had Michael malice on
my podcast today and you know what we
did something very very good he also
said this on my show which is you can
find it if you think the possibility of
peace is worse than the possibility of
war there must be something wrong with
you and he says that he has a good
metaphor that North Korea is like a
hostage situation we've said that before
there's 28 million 27 million hostages
the protocol is you try to get the
hostage taker to put his gun down and
you do that always first by dialogue and
then you whether that means reassuring
him with a film that might work
but that's how you do it first you want
to save the people and it is there are
people it's terrible in North Korea they
have concentration camps they have Genet
they had genocide in the 90s
it's a ruthless regime that tells you
something
containment doesn't work containment
containment doesn't make the hostages
feel really good
no it holds the line' yeah this this
could mean a hostage taker a hostage
might actually think Trump is saving me
yeah all right they know so what do you
make now in terms of we've had some time
since this historic summit in the
meeting to kind of see some of the
fallout the discussion people's you know
take different sides in terms of their
opinion of what they think transpired
well I think it's still a net plus right
for the President and for the world like
there is still hope there is skepticism
but I think that it's important to note
that the skepticism isn't necessarily
about President Trump unless you're like
just an anti Trump person the skepticism
is about North Korea and kim jeong-hoon
because the regime that's repeatedly
lied they've repeatedly agreed to
similar things like what they agreed to
in the communique the other day with the
president that back in 1996 and 2000 and
then in 2005 and then 2006 so they
that's repeated so I think the
skepticism one journalists are skeptical
two conservatives are skeptical but
three good the skepticism is also about
the North Koreans just as it was about
the Iranians I also think that in some
ways there
this tribal nature of who you're going
to trust if you are a Democrat and you
trusted Obama you thought the Iran deal
was a really good one and you also might
think that the personnel that they had
like Secretary John Kerry you had a lot
of trust in him
conservatives did not and I think you're
just seeing the mirror image of that now
so Republicans will say I trust
President Trump I think he knows what
he's doing I mean we didn't get it all
in one day we never expected that but
they also respect the people that work
for him so John Bolton Mike Pompeo
whereas it's just on the other side it
would just be back and forth thank you I
also think though that when it comes to
the cost to Americans to have our troops
in South Korea and in the region and to
do these exercises it's not just that
it's in put out it's not just like a
lost cause I do think that it is our
strategic national interest for us to
keep a presence there because you don't
have to revamp it back up especially
because we know that there are always
dangers lurking around the corner
okay now Jesse you know obviously and
Dana brings up a good point about sort
of the tribalism of it and there's
people yes that do trust you know
President Trump but because also perhaps
they've looked at the record of what he
has promised and what he has delivered
an hour is it okay these days to be
optimistic about hopefully having you
know good outcomes trust but verify
right and what happened during the Obama
administration I mean they gave billions
of cash to the Ayatollah they had a
really bad trade with Bergdahl handed
over five top Taliban members they
botched the Paris climate deal they
botched TPP they botched pretty much
everything they touch the Iraq status of
forces agreement and then Trump comes in
to try to broker a peace deal gives up
almost nothing and the same people that
praised Obama now are complaining
I mean Clinton and Carter went over
there and built two nuclear reactors
gave them millions of dollars what
happened just the other day I think
Obama gave Trump the keys to the White
House and said oh yeah by the way I've
done nothing on North Korea for eight
years but now it's the biggest problem
you're gonna have to deal with that good
luck
so Trump tries to step up and bring
peace to the peninsula and all he hears
is a hundred-percent negativity it just
destroys the media narrative that he's
this big war monger when he goes there
to make peace and they don't want to get
any credit for trying to get peace I'm
not saying it's a done deal it's far
from a done deal there's a potential
here for a great deal but all the
deputies now have to hammer out the
details there's no you know verification
there's no inspections the phase-out is
still up in the air we don't know
whether they're going to destroy or when
they're going to destroy all these
facilities that all has to be hammered
out but the spirit of the summit was
very strong and the political will
between the two leaders appears to be
very positive and I think now we let the
little guys hammer it out and we'll see
what happens yeah once so the president
used you know rhetoric that some thought
was inflammatory but he was quite
specific in saying that he feels that
that played a part in terms of bringing
North Korea to the table where
ultimately you know he used the
diplomacy to be able to achieve these
ends I think I read it differently Kim
but I think he said he regretted some of
the language that he's used in them but
he also said that he thought it was
helpful in getting them to this point no
I think he said he regretted and
understood that it was provocative
languages I think what he said but to
the larger point here I think the big
news today is you know what the Pentagon
didn't know that he was offering to give
up military exercises with the South
Koreans and maybe most importantly the
South Koreans didn't know it and the
South Koreans have played a key role in
trying to make this deal happen and they
they're surprised too so what you have
is kind of seated by seat-of-the-pants
Donald Trump working by the gut say oh I
think this work this work what about our
allies I mean this is something that you
know when you think about it you say as
everybody else on the panel has talked
about let's go back and look at past
criticism of something like the Iran
deal oh my gosh at that point it was
said that this was evidence of Obama's
inexperience that he was a celebrity
president didn't understand the threats
the world faced of course he got a deal
that stopped Iran from developing
nuclear weapons what we have here is no
such thing from present no guarantee no
method of verification nobody on the
ground no assurances no details in two
days
I'm sorry it's just hurry there was a
signed deal Jesse and that's what the
deal said we stop just start he stopped
and nothing else nothing from the North
Korean so what you get is when Obama sat
down and said and I think this is a
seven in the midst of his campaign he
said you know I'm willing to meet with
people who represent repressive regimes
because it's an opportunity to build
bridges to talk oh my goodness the
Conservatives the Republicans said what
is he doing he's coddling our enemies
and he's alienating our allies when
Trump does it oh this is historic and
the American media is the enemy talk
about hypocrisy can I explain just the
difference between I think we have a
strong muscular pro-american president
like Donald Trump when he is willing to
sit down and talk to America's enemies
there's a different posture there
there's a difference between someone
like that and someone like Obama who did
an apology tour
who talked down American greatness and
American exceptionalism and his
willingness to go and talk to America's
enemies and not cut a great vigilant
deal this is the difference let me let
me just say that I guess there's the
session the way you guys see it is it's
just team sports it's just if you like
Obama you like this if you like Trump
you like this but I think let's get away
from that for a second let's just look
at what the deal entails and what you
see is and we talked about this moment
ago a hundred and thirty thousand people
living in South Korean gulags at this
moment so are tough strong president
there's nothing about nothing in the
can't believe that anyone complained
about actually something that happened
that was very favorable for this country
for North Koreans for South Koreans for
the world
in general give a chance for this to
work you don't like it abused fire and
fury you don't like it if we go to war
you don't like it if we sit down and
have engaged in diplomatic relations of
course I do I like do you want anyone go
for good the only thing I was gonna say
is that if you are skeptical of all of
this and you're looking for somebody
that you might be able to look to that
you respect and you trust that is not a
partisan but that is an expert in the
region Victor
Chah is somebody who is a darshawn
professor and he was going to well he's
worked in the government as well but he
was going to be president Trump's
ambassador to South Korea that didn't
end up working out because you have some
differences if you read his op-ed today
in the New York Times you would see like
he's actually pretty upbeat he likes the
strategy he thinks that it's all headed
in the right direction of course there's
a list of all the complicated questions
that are yet to be answered but overall
like at this point he's quite upbeat and
positive and if you're just looking for
someone who's not a partisan and their
take on it I think he's a good one
mm-hmm you know it's not totally tribal
with me one I'm a little concerned about
suspending the war games or
quote-unquote military readiness
preparation I think you need to be
prepared for the North Koreans and
that's why you have them they're
defensive in posture they see them the
North Koreans as offensive they're
they're there just in case something
happens in the North invades and we want
our allies to be prepared and on point
so we can ratchet those back up at any
time the big one doesn't come till
spring 2019 so I understand why he did
it in order to kind of encourage
goodwill there but it's not such thing
I'm you know crazy about happening I
want these exercises to continue I think
they're important so why is why is the
president than saying oh Kim ISM I'm
trying a guy he's trustworthy
all right Gregg ins I just find it
interesting that the the same people who
have spent decades pleading for dialogue
are now having when delivered with a
giant bow and I think that's what really
hurts is that Trump is delivering what
liberals have been promising and
claiming as their expertise and I think
it disturbs and destroys their soul to
see I I mean it's amazing to me to see
how many people are actually against
peace and return to the analogy of
hostages there are hostages in that
country right that what what President
Trump is doing is negotiating with the
hostage taker which is exactly the
protocol that you do and if it doesn't
work you know that Trump gave the hard
sell he exhausted every option before
you go in there and rescue the hostages
and that's the point rescuing the
hostages means they're going to die this
is the actually the Oh
only way that that you can do it and I I
don't know I think I think I am
optimistic about it because I think that
Trump has is getting getting the North
Korea regime to think past the sale he's
like a car salesman he got Kim into the
Corvette for the test-drive yeah that
video is brilliant with that and I and
and hats off to I guess it was Bolton
Bolton's team who did that video but the
fact is that was the Corvette they got
Kim to get the feel of what it's like to
be in an American car named freedom yeah
well that may showed him that he brought
look at my car you checked out the Beast
he was yes yes exactly exactly and then
he made that point about the thumb you'd
be curious to see it years going forward
whether or not CIA had some Intel to do
that that would be persuasive in the art
of the deal